es sind immer wieder pilzesammler die
bei ihren spaziergängen durch den wald
auf wichtige beweismittel stoßen
so auch bei der verschwundenen birgit am
1 nach fünf jahren ungewissheit jetzt
der traurige fund die knochen der damals
54 jährigen lagen im wald bei
büchenbeuren im hunsrück persönliche
gegenstände und ein gebiss abgleich
schufen klarheit
jetzt hat die mordkommission wieder
einen ansatz für ihre ermittlungen
der fall birgit am eis ist aber kein
einzelfall
2009/10 findet ein pilzsammler die
leiche von christian b kurz nach dem
fund der leiche kann die polizei zwei
tatverdächtige festnehmen
sie waren mit ihm in einer
dreiecksbeziehung nach dem brutalen mord
mit 27 messerstichen sitzen beide vor
gericht
ohne einen aufmerksamen pilzesammler
gäbe es diesen prozess gar nicht
die leiche wäre vielleicht nie gefunden
worden 2017 findet ein spaziergänger die
knochen eines babys in viernheim in
hessen monate lang sucht die polizei
nach der mutter sogar die fernsehsendung
aktenzeichen xy bittet um hinweise
2013 finden pilzesammler die knochen von
maria böhme damals 26 aus regensburg
überschüttet mit lösch kalkskelett ganz
in der nähe des reiterhofs auf dem sie
den abend vor ihrem verschwinden beim
grillen war die kleine peggy knobloch
aus lichtenberg in oberfranken
der 48 jährige thomas göttmann aus
büttelborn die achtjährige levke
strasheim aus cuxhaven
die zehnjährige adelina sie alle wurden
ermordet und herzlos im wald abgeladen
aber dank der pilzesammler kommt die
polizei bei den ermittlungen weiter so
wie bei bürger damals auch wenn noch
kein mörder gefunden wurde
immerhin gibt es jetzt einen ansatz
und ich möchte nun sprechen mit meinem
kollegen jörg völkerling denn bei ihm
ist jetzt wolfgang iwanski der mann der
beim pilzesuchen die leiche von maria
böhme fand bevor wir mit ihm sprechen
ist es ja einfach eine sehr wichtige
frage warum einfach pilzesammler auch
immer so zum wichtigen mosaikstein in
den ermittlungen werden ich selbst habe
das ja in vielen fällen schon erlebt der
fall peggy der jetzt auch schon den
bericht erwähnt wurde war ja ein wo auch
wahnsinnig viel auch schon der
bundeswehr mit tornados haben mit
tauchern untersucht wurde das mädchen zu
finden das gelang nicht und erst in pill
zusammen wird war 15 jahre später in der
lage durch zufall weil er eben nicht so
gezielt suchte sondern durch den wald im
thüringer wald stt riffs und dabei diese
skelette elefant und den ermittlern
damit einen wesentlichen puzzle steine
in die hand gab
denn erst wenn man eine leiche hat kann
man einfach nach dna spuren suchen kann
mögliche todesursache feststellen
und genau wie du gesagt hast bei mir ist
wolfgang urban ski er ist derjenige
gewesen mit dem im jahr 2013 dann auch
die ermittlung von maria baum war
wirklich anfahrt gebunden haben und
erobern ski können sie einfach noch mal
schildern wie dieser tag damals für sie
von außen ist der achter september 2013
haben uns verabredet mit bekannten
wollten eigentlich grillen gesagt okay
dann gehen wir mal ein bisschen
waldpilze kassen dazu zu gehören
ja indem wir eingegangen durch gestreift
nochmal natürlich gibt's die schönsten
besten nur sind wir über eine google
nicht gestolpert mal gesehen schön
ausgehobene grube
und dann haben wir als erstes im
blickfeld gleich den den schädel und
skelette und dann nach umsehen haben uns
gesehen dass den sparten gegen ist und
eine leere wasserflasche
da habe ich gesagt zum 1
streiter halt raus hier das ist ein
tatort dann müssen wir das nicht dass
man irgendwas verbiegen auf den weg
am neuen weg aber dann ein paar jogger
getroffen haben gesagt wo hier die
polizei wäre dass man das melden können
ich habe alle gerne auch gelungen
gestand okay da müssen wir die 110
wählen
nach der wahl hat die dame am anderen
ende auch nicht um die frage wo wir sind
für die polizei war er dann relativ
schnell auch der zusammenhang mit maria
bader klar weil das waren bernhardswald
ganz in der nähe war maria baum auch
zuletzt gesehen wurde sie wahrscheinlich
nicht gleich wie ist das heute für sie
wenn sie in den wald gehen
man sieht dann noch so das gefühl um
gottes willen stuhl wo ich jetzt wieder
über eine leiche oder haben sie schon
mal andere funde gemacht die dann nicht
unbedingt hingehören nein also man geht
nicht in wald sagt ich finde ich die
lage
das ist man geht im alten suppelt andere
dinge habe ich schon gefunden natürlich
hinterlassen ich auch geworden der
zivilisation also abwahl etc
es findet man öfters ab und zu mal
sachen die wirklich nicht da hingehören
ansonsten drohten handgranate war ja ich
hatte mal vor jahren das ist ein minus
20 jahre also a double von der hand
gerade geschehen
ich wusste nicht dass in der truppe ist
und ich habe irgendwas ist ja keine sagt
ok direkte ziehen uns zurück habe ich ja
weiter nicht weiter verfolgt wie ist
denn für sie heute dieses erlebnis von
vor sieben jahren begleitet sie das in
ihren träumen haben sie albträume davon
oder wie empfinden sie das heute also
halb drücken habe ich nicht davon
mich freut es dass der täter gefasst
wurde und dass eben doch uns in
verhandlung hatte und dass er die tat
dann sagen wir ja er ist jetzt geteilt
worden ist uns ist also im wir sind
stolz darauf dass wir die tochter der
vermittelt zurückgeben konnten unter uns
eine
mit bei der besetzung dabei zu sein
genau und christian f der verlobte ist
ja jetzt vor einem monat verurteilt
wurden erst zu lebenslanger haft mit
besonderer schwere der schuld verurteilt
wurden und das urteil wird noch
überprüft vom bgh wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren